a few days ago david did a story about a
man who went to an arlington city
council meeting
and said the punishment for being gay
is death or it should be death
that man came from the same church as a
pastor that we're going to look at today
in a disturbing clip that has gone viral
it's steadfast church is the name of the
church
and
he said
just like his i guess colleague or
someone else who went to that same
church the gay people should be killed
but this one went as far as to
specifically say how they should be shot
in the back of the head
warning this is very disturbing but
let's take a look
the answer is the solution for the
homosexual in 2022 here in the new
testament here in the book of romans
that they are worthy of death
these people should be put to death
every single homosexual in our country
should be charged with the crime the
abomination of homosexuality that they
have they should be convicted in a
lawful trial they should be sentenced
with death they should be lined up
against the wall and shut in the back of
the head
that's what god teaches
that's what the bible says
you don't like it you don't like god's
word because that is what god said i
mean
what is there to say to that
it's disturbing it's disgusting all the
things but
the fact that he's pretending to be
expressing these views because he feels
it is the word of god is horrible i mean
you are hateful deeply deeply hateful
you don't feel called by god to say and
do these things you have a deep hatred
in your heart
and are desperate to find an excuse to
spew it everywhere that you can in the
world
and then let's address what he's saying
seriously i don't know why we would do
that but let's do it anyways if you
don't understand that your specific
religions sets of beliefs can't be
enforced on everyone in a country you
don't understand our constitution you
don't understand how a functioning
society would work
free democratic society so even if he
genuinely believed this
was his religion this is what god was
calling him to do
there is absolutely no way
you could figure out a way to justify
enforcing your specific beliefs on
an entire country of people and wanting
to
just got a lot of rage i just almost had
like a heart palpitation um what the
heck
and kill people because of your religion
or your interpretation of your religion
and let me make something clear there
are wonderful christians there are
beautiful so many christians i'm
christian raised and
tons of people around me are
amazing christians they serve
the country they serve the people around
them
they see jesus's teachings as being
service oriented
helping people
who are disadvantaged vantage loving
people unconditionally all those things
and they're amazing
this is not all christians
and like i said before i don't even
think this is christianity i think this
man
is using christianity
to express views he already has deep
down in his heart because he is a
hateful person
for some reason the concept of anyone
being different anyone loving different
scares him
probably born on a deep deep insecurity
but then he uses
a
religious text to justify spewing his
hatred
and i'm noticing as
broader society moved forward like over
the last few generations we've moved
forward a lot on lgbtq issues
a small portion is kind of reacting to
that progress by launching way backwards
and we can't
allow this as a country we can't allow
a small minority of this country
to inflict pain
on
other groups of people just because of
their weird distorted perverted
understanding of their own religion
that's not acceptable
and i think every religious person or
non-religious person should be able to
unite around the fact regardless of our
disagreements otherwise
that this should not be allowed and this
should not be accepted in our country
he's calling for the murder
of people just because they live
differently than him and don't subscribe
to his particular set of religious
religious beliefs
as i said i was raised christians i know
tons of christians in my life and i know
all of them would be just as disgusted
as i am by watching this and so
how about you go out if you're someone
like him and you believe what he
believes how about you actually do
something in the world that's good i see
this
and i i had someone point this out to me
and i never want to forget to point this
out tons of people who are religious
do amazing things with it that's what i
do with my religion i do good things
with it
it it motivates people to do good things
and tons of the
charity and service that we see in our
country is done by people who are
motivated by the religious beliefs so
this isn't a massive thing on religion
this is
people who only want to use a religion
to feel better than other people
and that's him and i just wish i could
look at him in the face and say how
about you do something good for the
world right now you're sitting you're
festering in your hate for other people
and you're trying to get your audience
and your followers and supporters to
believe the same thing and you're
threatening people's lives what good is
that doing for the world what good is
that doing for you for the god that you
believe in what good is that doing uh in
living a life of jesus
it's not
everyone understands if they read
enough of the bible while there's a lot
of stuff in there like whoa what what's
going on i can't
at least if you zero in on the jesus
stories
he was a very very giving and loving and
serving person
so how about you go out and you give and
you love and you serve
you disgusting human human being
but no you just want to stand there you
want to get the attention of people
and you want to talk about how much you
hate people for being different than you
it's so i'm so sick of having to listen
to this
and
he should be arrested right
that's a criminal level of
threatening of violence
a judge did rule luckily that uh
steadfast church will be evicted
um they're gonna be evicted for allowing
threats of violence so hooray on that
but super scary and harmful stuff
you can hear further discussions about
this topic in general i'm always getting
fired up about people going after
already marginalized groups
for absolutely no reason on my channel
if you want to watch that you can go to
luke beasley on youtube
or if you're watching this on youtube
listening to podcast there will be a
link in the description you can click to
check me out be greatly appreciated